so we're talking about term limits and i
think the reason why everyone's bringing
up term limits is because there's been
some stories out of the hill about uh
senator dianne feinstein she's 88 years
old she seems to have some cognitive
impairment
that's what people are saying that's the
stories that are going around now first
off i do want to say uh some people were
bringing up some good points about
senators or representatives in the first
place uh policymakers a lot of times a
politician is just kind of the
placeholder to get elected the
policymakers are actually their staff
right so a lot of times the staff are
doing 90 80 of the work that a
politician would do so a little bit of
this ah she forgets conversations and
some stuff may not be quite as fair as
people are making it out to be um
but here's the thing with term limits
and i said this yesterday we actually
have term limits in this country
and what the term limit is is they're
limited to the number of years in their
term
we as the people get to choose rather
they get to continue to a next term and
really honestly if we would actually
participate and this is kind of a lazy
[ __ ] way
of
of us thinking about government with
term limits we're like oh well
why would we want to make sure we
participate in our democracy and know
civics and know about our government and
how it works and how it operates i don't
want to know any of that what i want to
do is make sure that the politicians
just can't be politicians forever
and it really is it's not the correct
way to thinking in democracy are you on
the same page as me or am i just the
only one
let me take us on a little abstract
metaphysical roundabout to get to like
understanding why term limits at the
federal uh level would be a bad idea
okay okay and i'm gonna do that in a
really unpredictable way because i'm
gonna talk about presidential primaries
for a second okay
uh as you guys know people [ __ ] almost
as much about the presidential primary
calendar the system that's used these
individual contests that happen over a
series of a month and a half
um and they complain about the
unrepresentativeness of iowa and and new
hampshire and then south korea you know
and then it's not fair why isn't
michigan in that is in florida if you
have been paying attention to politics
long enough you know it's triggered you
know uh wars to to on the calendar to
move up and sanctions and all kinds of
[ __ ] right and so what people say oh we
need a national primary that's what we
need we need a national primary it's not
fair that you know iowa gets to choose
our nominee everybody should vote and
everybody should vote on the same day
okay and that makes sense i mean that is
a feel-good solution that sounds like it
logically
would be an improvement but when you
think it through you start to see very
quickly it opens up a whole new basket
of different problems right so you're
exchanging one set of issues for another
at any time really that you do a reform
you get that but particularly here and
term limits are very similar
you know if you were to switch the
federal offices to term limits
number one what people should understand
is the [ __ ] that's going really wrong
in dc right now i mean they ask there
are a couple of exceptions but generally
it's because of too much turnover in the
republican party not too little right we
had a lot of states people people who
you know they were staller conservatives
but they believed in the institution of
senate of the house they believed in the
constitution they believed in the rule
of law
and they over time got purged out and
replaced with these radical wing bats
you know
so um what we see this in the state
legislatures as well instead of problems
from lifetime politicians and a lot of
them
most people are not going to become a
lifetime politician be frank okay i mean
most people don't serve six seven terms
in the senator in the house they come
and they go faster than that and the
ones that don't are are do that are
generally serving in a state like
kentucky mitch mcconnell is
electorally inoculated from any kind of
check or mechanism to end his tenure but
generally speaking when you look at
what's [ __ ] up in the house and what's
[ __ ] up in the senate right now it's
coming from these people who were
uh brought in as replacements not the
long-timers and the long-timers
definitely have a lot of corruption
issues you know blah blah blah they
could have health issues like feinstein
uh and refuse to relinquish their seat
but the one thing that they did care
about was the institution and preserving
the institution and now that is really
falling apart
well you know i i in some states there
are term limits for legislators like in
missouri in my great state of missouri
and they pass term limits on on a ballot
that the voters and the voters like oh
this is fantastic we get to make sure
that the good policy makers don't in
government anymore because that's really
the danger that you have
with
term limits like in missouri the
lobbyists run the state
special interest runs our state there's
one guy in particular rex syncfield who
everyone knows his name in the state
because he pretty much runs a republican
party in the state he gets to choose the
candidates and a lot of them aren't they
don't know [ __ ] about government because
here's what happens is that a legislator
goes to the state legislature like
missouri and in missouri their number
one focus and their number one policy is
the budget because they have to balance
the budget yeah a lot of these people
have no clue what a state budget looks
like they don't know have no idea and by
the time they figure it out they're not
allowed to be politicians anymore so in
other words what they once they figure
out actually how government works and
how to do the thing called uh governing
they can't be governing body anymore
they're not part of policy anymore so
then what happens is
they have to look for a job in state
politics in missouri
and to stay in politics so the natural
thing is to go to a lobbying firm so
that way they can lobby the next round
of idiots that don't know what they're
doing in government to explain to them
what they want them to pass and how they
want to do it so just because it sounds
great that your politicians
would only have a certain amount of time
to be politicians because the thing is
well if they can't get this done in this
many years then then [ __ ] them right
right right but here's the thing is that
sometimes it takes a long time and we're
never going to stop governing we're
never going to stop policy right it's
not going to be like one day we're like
hey the government's perfect now
everything's great we're going to stop
doing any governing any policy we're
going to stop that stuff and besides
like i mean the only i mean
you are getting or not getting policy
out of the state legislature or the
federal one for one reason and one
reason only and that's party control or
the party breakdown the state
legislators don't have these super
majority requirements in the senate so
they they can pass legislation without
the filibuster and they and they run
through though many of them have super
majorities anyway but you know tony
you've touched on something really
important and i'll use the federal
system to describe
think about how complex the nation is
there's so much [ __ ] going on just this
week we've got this massive
international war
problem right
you've got climate change you've got
farm
prices you've got this border [ __ ] with
the supply chain right you've got so
many so much complexity in running a
government and this would be true at the
state level as well so what this elect
means is for members like a senator
can't be an expert on agricultural
policy and national security okay it's
pretty rare to find that and you need at
least some working expertise or focus
for these members because even if
they're really well versed they ran a
farm in montana or whatever
they are still gonna be heavily reliant
on
the staff that's working for them but
mostly
you guys are really gonna hate this
mostly on industry that they're
regulating will help them with the with
understanding the policies right
so for instance for instance the uh the
trucker thing where greg abbott is
trying to stuff up the trucker the
trucking industry has spoken out and
there's probably a lot of policy makers
uh in texas and on the hill that are
listening to industry experts on
trucking and why this is horrible for
for one instance no doubt and and you so
the more so so even so the more you
bleach expertise
from an institution a state legislature
or a federal the federal legislature
what you will end up with is a more
industry
heavy
reliance on
on somebody else i mean
if you're replacing every people people
by every two to four terms if it's a
two-year term what you have done is
wiped out all that institutional
knowledge and you're empowering the very
people that drive you the most [ __ ]
nuts which are the lobbyists
right well and and because the lobbyists
are now pushing the boneheads which it
will be a bunch of boneheads in congress
because and i don't mean stupid people i
just mean people who who aren't
experienced i'll give you an example and
maybe this will clear it up for people
is there is a special lady from
california who has a white board and i
would love to see katie porter be the
senator from california nothing would
please me more than to watch her be
senator from california until she's 400
years old and that white board is worn
down to a thread um katie porter is so
important in making policy and the
reason why is because katie smart porter
is very smart she's very pointed in her
questioning she's very good at it in a
committee meeting to hold private
industry accountable where they need to
be held accountable she's very very
[ __ ] good at it
and i want katie porter there not just
fighting for californians but for
fighting for all americans for those
policies and if we if we would limit her
to how many terms she could serve
she would not be there fighting for you
and there are bad politicians let's face
it there are bad politicians and i don't
just mean like crooked i just mean
they're not very good policy makers they
don't know how the legislator works they
really don't care how the legislator
works they're there for fundraising and
to be a placeholder like i was saying
before but there are politicians out
there that aren't just the placeholder
they are policy makers this is what they
do this is what they're interested in
they're interested in an area that they
aren't an expert in finding staff that
can be an expert to make sure that that
policy in that industry even though they
know nothing about it works for the
american people and also works for
american private industry because these
things go hand in hand in our country
like you're saying but the last thing we
want is for the american worker the
american people to to
get put on the back burner because
politicians cannot
do anything but
actually listen to private industry on
expertise and we need we need both we we
have to have a mixture of both
when we're making policy in this country
but it is so vitally important that our
policymakers that are the good ones that
are the great ones and most of them we
don't even know their names right
because they are actually our policy
makers they're not trying to get on tv
they're not trying to be famous that's
right yeah no they're wondering that you
didn't even hire a policy
like chief of staff he hired a comms
person
right exactly which made sense right
because he wasn't planning on showing up
and doing it right right well he's hired
a social media manager because that's
what he is he's a social media
influencer that's exactly right but you
know here let me be fair to our
legislators though because there's many
on both sides of the aisle that do go in
there sincerely i mean you may [ __ ]
hate the policies right but they go in
there with sincere intent and that speak
but but but here's the thing that people
should look this book up if they if
they're interested it's called the
electoral connection it's and it's for
people who study political science from
the behavioral perspective it is the
bible right and the reason why is
because it argues look politicians it
doesn't matter if it's a state
legislature governor federal congress
whatever they're all
single-minded
seekers of re-election or the next
election right if they're moving from
the house to the senate or whatever like
that and what that means is
all other goals have to be proximate to
achieving that goal first if you don't
have the office you cannot make the
policy pursuing a banning abortion or
fixing climate change or whatever it is
and so
you know even though it may look like
aoc is this purely driven
you know person for principal
it's a function of her electoral
conditions right and you could have
taken an aoc
and run her in a swing race and she
would have to behave in some ways
different i certainly wouldn't have uh
not as different as people might imagine
right but um definitely different in in
terms of like the the socialism you know
um you know cosplay i guess we'd say
right
new deal all the stuff all the stuff
that tucker carlson uses against he
calls her sandy and so like the public
looks at these politicians say like
between a um
gillibrand an aoc and it's all to them
it's just about will right it's like
what this person has principle and that
person doesn't but really
it's those electoral lines right if
you're in a safe district if you're a
joe manchin you're facing
a 35 trump point trump differential okay
so like that means that 70 basically of
joe manchin's potential voter poll
is republican
right so like when he when he does [ __ ]
yes it might be that he owns stock and
pharma and this and that and oil
whatever but the end of the [ __ ] day
joe manchin's like every other
politician except for christian cinema
because from now on we'll have to ask
her that um and he's a single-minded
seeker of reelection what he he's doing
what he thinks gives him the most
probability to stay in the senate and
continue to make policy right so
at the end of the day guys this this
electoral connection this idea that
politicians are driven by reelection
isn't meant to make them sound
you know uh cruel or uncaring or
artificial or whatever it's just the
truth of the matter is if you if you
want to be there to make policy you have
to win and i mention all of that guys
because we already have a situation
where our members like maybe they look
like they don't do much but that's
because they're spending 40 hours a week
dialing for dollars and it is so
humiliating to run or serve in any uh
competitive race now
um seat or whatever
you have to raise so much money that
you're spending almost a full-time job
on money raising every single week and
in the house that starts almost as soon
as the next session starts so senators
have it a little bit less pressured at
their six-year terms and imagine if
instead you had to
you know if you limited these house
people to two to three terms you're
resetting that fundraising operation
every time as well right so it is it is
one of those things like a national
primary if we had a national primary by
the way it's it's true that iowa would
be ignored because there's no people in
iowa right but the the presidential
calendar where the candidates go and
spend money on stuff will be in major
cities major states with major
populations right so instead you'll see
all the primary love in california in
new york in texas and
everybody else will get the leftovers
maybe in florida right where the big
populations are because you know in a
direct primary it's just a matter of
winning that national popular vote and
how are you going to do that you're
going to do that in big populated areas
so janie brings up a comment here she
said that's bad that's why they don't
get as much done um and that is and you
know that's that's probably a good point
uh but also that's a point for the staff
right because that's why a lot of these
politicians rely on their staff because
they're working so hard
on
on
fundraising in some of these races that
they have to rely on their staff to make
these policies to be the policymakers
while they're the placeholder as i said
before
yeah it's terrible and it's you know
i mean imagine if you're spending 30
hours a week on call time i mean it's if
you guys have more interest in this it's
sometimes firewalled sometimes not but
60 minutes put out something about five
years ago called dialing for dollars
with david jolly actually i suppose is a
little longer now and it was his he he
just refused to do it he got into the
house from florida
realized he was going to spend 30 to 40
hours a week in buildings across so each
party has a building across the street
from capitol hill that they do this call
time in and if you've ever worked in a
phone center because i have those are
the most depressing [ __ ] environments
on the face of the earth dude like
you're in this cubicle you're on this
headset thing i mean it's [ __ ] sad so
imagine katie porter who we all love you
know sitting in this booth being a
telemarketer being a television she's
basically a telemarketer and it's our
system
of wild i mean we our electoral system
is completely [ __ ] up i mean and i
think people know that they don't really
know it and you can't understand it
until you've done a comparative analysis
that looks at how elections get you know
done in canada or the uk even which is
the most like us or france like that you
can't just do and say whatever the [ __ ]
you want for however the
long you want to do it and based on a
pay-to-play
system where money is speech and
therefore the money to have speech and
the poor don't right so you know it is
um it is sad that our legislators are
forced to to go through this uh that
said everyone on the show understand the
reason you're not getting [ __ ] is
because the republican party is not an
honest opposition it has no interest in
governing it's never going to give us
[ __ ] it's never going to give a [ __ ] we
have to roll over them electorally
when you know that that is that is a
good point and the reason why it's a
good point is because
we we as a
as an electorate cannot continue to not
pay attention and not be educated on
this stuff and that's why i say the term
that the politicians have is the term
that you choose them to have you're the
one who gets to choose that these
politicians are your politicians and to
say term limits is the answer is a lazy
way of looking at democracy as opposed
to just [ __ ] participating in it
exactly you know and in terms of like
there's always gonna be i mean that's
why the republican machine is so great
there's always exceptions there's always
a couple things and if you take it and
make the whole issue defined by dianne
feinstein's declining mental health and
unwillingness to leave office then
obviously term limits are going to seem
very logical but she is an exception
most people do leave without dying in
office
you know what
it's not like professors they just die
in office right which is why there's no
jobs for phds you know but um you know
most most people do end up leaving
office so there is the one the reason
they do these state funerals for the
ones that don't
or these big deals is it is foreign if
it was all of them when they couldn't do
it
well in a lot of these politicians
including dianne feinstein i mean they
kind of have a lifetime appointment
right i mean
because the incumbency is the gold
standard when it comes to getting
re-elected and that's the other thing
that i think we discount um with
because a lot of people think oh well
that's a that is an actual
that's a pro a con or a pro to getting
term limits and it's like not exactly
not exactly because actually
getting into coming out of office is a
huge statement for democracy i think a
lot of people
a lot of people discount like when eric
cantor lost his seat in a primary like
that was a huge signal in our democracy
right that was a huge signal that the
establishment was probably not in
control as much as they wanted to be and
it was it was just a preempt for what
was to come with trump it was just this
sign and and i think a lot of people
discount that just like they kind of
discount this 2022 midterm about how
important
not just the elections gonna be
for what the makeup of the house and the
senate are our governorships our
lieutenant governor some of these state
legislators the secretary of state
not just that but also the signal that
it sends to the country and to the
electorate if we reject trumpism all
across this country in the 2022 midterm
that is going to send a huge signal to
the party who is hellbent hell-bent on
supporting putin and fascist and letting
eric greitens be the [ __ ] nominee in
in as a state senator in their party and
possibly letting donald trump who may be
federally indicted on criminal charges
at that point run for their seat in in
the republican party as the nominee in
2024 and and and it's not always that
they get to choose this person but they
really do they really do
they have the ability the machine has
the ability whether it's in either party
to really try to turn a person off or
turn them on and really tear them down
or prop them up and they've been
propping up donald trump for [ __ ] six
years and really you could probably make
the argument for seven years and they
continue to prop him up and the only
reason why is because they have no proof
no proof yet that the entire country
will reject trumpism they don't see 2020
as that proof but this midterm if we get
out and we drive the vote and we get to
the polls and we show the country not
just in in the makeup of our government
but show the country with an actual
election with actual numbers that we do
not want this [ __ ] this is all garbage
we don't want you passing laws uh
worrying about gay marriage worrying
about trans children we don't want you
passing walls to try to marry children
we don't want you passing laws taking
away liberty from women and taking away
their rights we don't want you doing
that we want you
and tell me i'ma interrupt because i'm
so glad you set that up okay because
you're exactly right we don't want that
and i want to leave the convo with this
imagine if we fail imagine if we just
get rolled over this fall what [ __ ]
message has that sent because you just
went through a laundry list a litany of
you know authoritarian
light at least
tracks that the gop is taking in the
states and if we fail to hold them to
account this fall
then they're gonna have
red license i mean it's just gonna be
a [ __ ] field day of of autocratic
[ __ ] coming from this republican
party not just in congress we're going
to see that we're going to see them come
hard they're going to investigate nancy
pelosi they're going to investigate joe
biden it's going to be oh it's going to
be [ __ ] complete [ __ ] abuse of the
investigation and they don't and they
aren't like us they're gonna do ever
they're gonna pull every [ __ ] media
trick they can pull they're gonna you
know in you know refer for criminal
charges any time they can they don't
they don't pull punches and so you know
when you mention
you know the stakes and how important it
is think about the opposite message if
we fail think about what it is said to
them
it basically gives them an open invite
to end democracy
absolutely and and that's why we have to
drive the vote it's not just about
winning these races um even even in
these in these places where we're safe
in these congressional races where we're
safe you have to get out and you have to
vote because you have to prove to the
country send a message it is so clear
the message just like the reason why the
reason why the world is so receptive to
joe biden is because he won by 8 million
votes because i truly do not believe
that 81 million people voted for joe
biden and a lot of people hear that and
they say well wait a second i say there
was a lot of those 81 million that voted
against trumpism they voted against
trumpism and that is so important to see
that that it's not just about picking
one politician or one party over the
other it really is about being
pro-democracy and standing on that
mantle of the democracy and saying this
is what we're going to protect we're
going to protect it and right now in our
country there is only one party just one
that is willing to protect your liberty
willing to protect our democracy protect
your freedom and your rights full stop
and there is another party that is
hellbent on taking it away from you if
they don't like who you are if you're
the other and that is fascism and it is
at our doorstep it is the threat and
don't think it will not come for you it
will it they're coming after women's
uteruses they're coming after children
right now they want to marry them they
want to they want to take consent away
from parents and they're starting with
trans kids with this consent thing but
they're doing it and they'll continue to
do it every
red state and every red legislator wants
to out florida florida at this point i
think what do you think rachel i think
you're exactly right and i have a 10
o'clock meeting
hey rachel thank you for joining us
everyone stick around everyone go follow
rachel on twitter at rachel bittikofford
thank you doc thanks for joining us
thanks for talking tournaments we'll
talk to you soon